good morning Millennials welcome back to
the chosen happy Wednesday it is hump
day a gorgeous day an absolutely
gorgeous day of the week like there are
so many worse ones so let's acknowledge
that speaking of gorgeous you know so
good
hey Jax
hey Claude how you turn
good really really good you sound well
good just so good you sound like
yourself
good it's so good to hear okay okay
that's enough Okay Kevin that's enough I
had a dream that we were at like
actually you weren't there I was like at
a camp and the whole Camp was like a
pageant and the winner of the pageant
gets like hand chosen by Morgan Wallen
to be his girlfriend it was such a weird
oh and like the leader of the pageant
kind of like Candace Bergen's role in
Miss Congeniality was played by Aunt
Connie from Young Sheldon why wasn't I
there
maybe subconsciously I think you post
too much of a threat to my like place in
the past that's what I'm thinking
honestly yeah it's possible yeah and you
just like knew that you couldn't compete
with me
exactly and so I didn't to be Morgan
wallen's girlfriend
right who won isn't that just like who
won the pageant
like I want to say me because it was my
dream and like if anyone's gonna win
something in my dream I bet your ass
better be me but I do believe I was
awoken before and Connie was able to
announce the winner were there any other
participants that we know
or a bunch of randoms you were competing
against
no there were like a bunch of like
like toddler and tiara type looking
girlies young girls no no no they
weren't toddlers but like they were in
Tiaras okay because that's an important
distinction are we saying Tiara or Tiara
no that's a word I'm starting to say so
much it's starting to sound like
gibberish okay
but is it
Tiara's story today where that word will
be in play and I just want to see how
how we say it and without you like
putting me on the spot because now I
don't know so we'll wait to find out
keep tuning in anywhere
we're about to find out if it's Tiaras
or Tiaras toddlers I think it's Tiaras
because Tiaras is like
obnoxious yeah
tiara
but now it honestly just sounds like
someone's name are you going to Tiara's
house later this is one of your favorite
conversation holes to go down like data
data Zara Zara
excuse me I really don't think that's
true it is
no it's not
someone who's on the receiving end of
your conversation at least for an hour a
day I can tell you that it is
I don't I think you're spreading lines
about me and you're using my poor memory
as like an entry into spreading rumors
okay
so I don't think that's true but is it
data or data no kidding
it's obviously data no I know that a
part of you like wants to continue
talking about that no not one inch of me
really cares but like do you think it's
Zara Zara
I don't know
Chef's Choice
yeah chef that's my favorite Chef's
Choice
better than Sophie's Choice
so much better yeah so much better I
think collectively like as a union we
need to stop saying Sophie's choice
because it's rooted in dark history and
maybe start saying Chef's Choice no it's
really mean difference yeah exactly
yeah Chef's Choice is like anything is
good just take one no it says it's like
the expert chooses like I don't want to
make a decision you choose
yeah and Sophie had a different choice
no a much more difficult one but
speaking of the Holocaust did you see
that they're making a movie about that
guy he's like the British Schindler I'm
sure you've seen the video of him he's
like an old man sitting in an audience
yes yes and he thinks he's like got some
TV special and then everyone in the
audience stands up and it's like all the
children that he saved in the Holocaust
as grown adults yes I did see that video
but I did not know they were making a
movie who's playing him Anthony Hopkins
be right back which is a name and a face
that you've heard of
and that you've seen
oh that's a nice man
let me tell you I've never seen this man
in my goddamn no I know but he's like
acclaimed and he has a nice looking face
I'm sure he'll do justice to the role I
just don't know him uh
yeah but he I think he's like a very
serious actor no for sure that name
gives like Oscar vibes yeah
what's the name of the familiar the
movie's going to be called The Power of
good
that's kind of a corny name is this on
Hallmark yeah it's giving TV movie but
it's Anthony Hopkins so it's not it's
getting made for TV yeah what was it the
power of good the power of good maybe
it's not too late to change the movie
title
hold on I got confused that's not the
name okay that's not the name
what is it that's just the name of a
documentary from 2002 about this man
it sounds like the name of a documentary
from 2002. yeah yeah yeah yeah and I'm
glad
maybe the work it's a working title like
maybe it's a work in progress they don't
have a title yet
yeah
well that sounds good yeah I'm excited
so me too
um my book club met last night
how did things go and while it is
technically the balabusta book club last
night we were the I hate Emily Henry
Club
okay and we just kind of got to talking
about you know her books and now they're
really not good
um but for some reason every time she
announces a book it's like shoots to the
top of every list she's kind of even
like industry plant vibe in the book
industry and now that you are a big
reader like can't you see that there's
clearly like politics in books and like
there's clearly favored authors there's
also authors who slay every time who
like don't get the respect that
recognition yeah we were all just like
how did this book come and the person
who chose it doesn't know hasn't read
Emily Henry books it was just everywhere
so she's like of course let me choose
this book it was you have to have a bad
experience in order to have your eyes
opened yeah I and it actually makes me
sad when I think about like all the
authors who are like so like deserving
of that sort of recognition and people
who can't even get their books on any
lists and it's like the second like an
Emily Henry book comes out it's number
one Goodreads suggested most read this
month why I have no idea and her first
book was Beach read which it was good
but it doesn't mean that like every book
from this author is gonna be something
that we have to read from now on but
people were treating it as such so I
read the next one people me too and that
was the book that burdened me
the book that burned me was Book Lovers
it was so bad
and what was the name of the book that
you just read Beach read happy place
happy they all sound the same yep
you should read Bee Tree just to see
what started this right like I've been
caught up in in her cycle like oh her
book is out I have to read it but I
actually never read the one that made
her you know in the cycle which is Beach
read yeah
and then the next book we chose is
actually another one that's like
everywhere whatever but I it actually
looks good it's called hello beautiful
oh and Napolitano yeah are you familiar
what are your thoughts I'm familiar with
her work she's you know a very swirly
girl no she's not not swirly in the
sentence but she's like a literary girly
like a Danish choicy oh yeah we were
because that's the thing it's like this
book we literally talked about for 45
seconds and then we all just like talked
about like gossip and like what else we
read this month and what our plans for
the summer we could not keep the
conversation on this book it was so
insubstantial if that's a word there was
not one theme we could talk about like
it was just horrible yeah I'm so curious
that you're gonna read hello beautiful
I don't know what it's about I don't
know whether it's good or not I'm sure
it's good because she's a good author
but
I feel like it's just very
literary
well that's like what we're looking for
now I just can't like you can't have a
book club with a book that's like make
some like that has nothing it's not
thought provoking it's not conversation
starting
right but you guys might be swinging the
pendulum too far the other way and again
like I don't know I'm gonna ask Dana
about the book and whether or not you
guys would like it because I'm sure it's
a good book that she liked but for
yearbook Club IDK the thing is it's too
late I'm worried you guys are over
correcting because even though you're
looking for a good book when I say
literary like you know it's the type of
books where it's like paragraphs of
descriptions and feelings and like and
sometimes it's a little more character
driven than plot driven it's not about
like ooh titillating what's happening
next it's like how is this person
developing over the course of the novel
that's fine that's fine and you know
what we're finding our footing in our
book club like we and I choose next so
like I'm so I'm the last one to choose
until we like start the cycle over again
I'm so motivated to choose the best book
of all time but what's great is that
we've had like two like actual zero star
stinker books so I really can't do worse
than anyone else like I'm not gonna be
the worst which is all I care what was
the other zero star
before you knew my name
was that a snitch's choice no it sounds
like one of those no it was horrible
okay but this is the point of a book
club like one yeah yeah it Sparks
interesting dialogue too you should
really cover the gamut of genres and
authors and yeah every month should be
different so it's not always going to be
a rose code no and when we hate the book
it's the funnest book club like we just
like crack up and just make fun of
everything in the book that's the
redheads
so it's okay speaking of we're recording
the redheads today really excited to
record with the swirlies
really a big day in the community yeah
because I think everybody probably liked
this book but it was also a good book
you know so uh if you want to become a
redhead I would start with this book it
was a quality book and it was a Danish
choice so you'll feel smarter for having
read it
that's the thing I love feeling smart it
doesn't happen a lot but when it does
it's worth all the work
it 100 you know like the way ever since
I read the rose code I've been acting
different and just like bringing up
lechley Park you know the secret
underground World War II British
decoding Center in everyday life is
beyond me and I really need to watch the
imitation game which is a movie about
Bletchley Park yeah it's not about our
girlies though it's about like Alan
Turing I think who we're like they
they're that's what came up in the book
because it was supposed to be like a
cool reference because they're like the
who the real people who the historical
fiction they're the history in the
historical fiction
um but I haven't seen imitation game
either let me ask you something because
when I was just reading about this movie
about the British Schindler he did like
the Kinder transport which is they sent
trains of Jewish children to Britain
like without their parents and I had
read about that recently somewhere and I
was feeling like it was the rose code
since you read it more no
no where did I read it
I don't know when you're as like
literary and scholarly as we are it's
hard to pinpoint our references you know
our bibliography I just get like deja vu
because I've been here before no I
understand yeah we got a lot of good
theories about what Deja Vu is and where
it comes from on and you know I heard
and I heard I mean I read in the
comments the redheads are actually more
um likely to experience stage of it more
susceptible
yeah yeah someone said which I don't
really subscribe to but I liked the
thought is that like you in a parallel
universe had already done this so you
were like harking back to that but not
even your former finger on it the way
that I sometimes feel about it it's like
if reincarnation is real
then maybe in a past life you've been in
this
mental state and you're like remembering
it but you can't put your finger on it
you know I feel that but I don't I don't
know if I believe in that reincarnation
like different lives for the Same Soul
you know like I just feel too connected
to Claudia like there's no way Claudia
is just a shell like I I am
Claudia you know
there's no way that I'm like this is
just a vessel body is kind of me a shell
excuse me no way like there's
literally no way that like this complex
Dynamic human being that I am is merely
a vessel for this universe no no but the
complex Dynamic human being is the part
that you take with you
no every every life that you live in
no I'm sorry no like you were uh peasant
in the Renaissance and you had this
attitude
but you're saying like I might not have
had this fupa yeah
no see I don't agree like I feel so
connected to different parts of my body
you feel so you feel that connected to
your physical being
yes
I wish I didn't
but I do but that could be a part of
like the makeup of your soul is that you
do get connected to your physical
I'm not just a who gets connected
to any physical shell I'm put into no I
think that you do and I think that's
what makes you so special as a soul
you commit to the role I also think it's
an inherently not Jewish belief okay but
I just want you to know a few months ago
we spoke on the podcast about
reincarnation and I was saying how like
I like the idea but I know it's not
Jewish and you said that there is like
something about it that's okay in
Judaism that it's like no yeah that it's
not that
it's not that I didn't say that because
I don't even know what you're talking
about you made it okay for me to explore
reincarnation no I did well I would you
know what Jackie I think you should
explore really anything so you can come
to the best conclusion but no I did not
say that I I think it makes a lot of
sense reincarnation
and yeah ideally like what we go through
this oh I think what I said no
what I said was like that this isn't you
know the purpose life life on this here
earth like this phase of you know life
isn't the soul Journey it's not the sole
purpose of of life there's more after
this but I don't think I said you're
gonna become a different like
you're not gonna become a bird I didn't
say bird I think human Souls you don't
even human
I mean it would only be fair in my
version yeah but it's like I guess you
know what Jax Jack's I guess we'll just
have to wait and say I guess we'll have
to wait to see what people say in the
comments
no like when we die like we'll say is
reincarnation real sound off in the
comments
because also think about how many humans
have lived on
the Earth since Earth's Inception it
would be oh it would be trillions that's
trillions of souls that God had to
create you know why not recycle a few
good ones okay on that note you know
what I always think
trillions of people right there's so
what are how many people are alive right
now seven billion right that seems low
but yeah sure
how is it possible that there aren't
like two people who were born on like
you know opposite sides of the Earth or
even you know next door neighbors who
don't look exactly there are
like I know there are infinite ways like
a person's face can look nose shape like
I know all that
but how is there not like another person
who looks just like me no like there is
it's called a doppelganger
but they never actually look that much
alike no maybe some of the ones that
you've seen but I'm telling you like if
you
looked at all seven billion people like
you would find Australian turkey like
you would
maybe I gotta head over to Australia
find Australian journey start a podcast
with her called good night but then also
like you know
the course of your life has changed how
you look maybe Australia he has her old
chin
right no but also like socioeconomic
circumstances change how you look based
on like you know if you work outside
right based on like uh your financial
situation based on what you eat like it
does that's true so I guess two people
even they could look so much alike they
could still change over the course of
their life based on like different
factors about you know where they're at
in their life right and they could take
just like different directions maybe
Australian turkey is a blonde
and I wouldn't even think to like you
know say we look alike because she's
blonde right
hmm Australians 30 sounds like a very
complex individual and I think I gotta
meet her yeah and she's a surfer so
she's really tan
right and of course very fit which is
why another reason nobody would be like
oh you look like Australian charity
because she's blonde and thin so they
wouldn't even take time to realize that
we have the exact same face right
hmm interesting that's true
humans are interesting
and you know what else is this upcoming
episode of the shows because we've got
five great stories and we've got deer
toasters Wednesday our weekly advice
segment and we've got some good ones
some girls have found themselves in some
pickles some pickles experts
which is sold out by the way I wanted to
thank all the toasters for like truly
showing up and showing out and the
pickle experts collab like went so viral
we were on the Today Show it was
everywhere and it sold out so sorry but
you can't get it and everyone who
ordered it like a lot of people are
starting to get it and they are all
posting like their taste tests on Tick
Tock it keeps coming up on my for you
page it makes me feel so cool and
they're loving it it's really like it's
shockingly good based on you know just
the title the name of it it's like
pickle wine question mark right yeah
what's so funny is pickle Spritz made a
lot of news and if we had nothing to do
with Spritz like that would probably be
something on a slow day a story that
would have been a fast five story like
today I saw a story but it didn't make
the cut that Skittles is coming out with
mustard flavored Skittles
okay copy us yeah but you know what oh
wait well first they couldn't turn it
around that quickly
at first I thought that was gross
actually but a little bit burst of
mustard as long as you're not eating it
with like Fruity Skittles
right I personally
loathe mustard but I know there are
people who are obviously put it on
everything people eat spoonfuls of it so
like you know what little must I mean
people love those mustard pretzels no
and it's like I could take a bite of my
Sonic pretzel and then pop in a mustard
Skittle
it's giving future it's giving life in
space
it's it's giving Ingenuity yeah I don't
have to deal with like the mess of
spreading the mustard getting myself out
of my hand create I have to like get a
dirty dish a dish Journey making a
utensil you know get a knife to spread
the mustard yeah
no it makes you think
interesting so
there's mustard Skittles go get some and
there's not any more Spritz pickle but
for those of you who did snag it
congrats
congrats now without further Ado it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by
Squarespace so Squarespace is the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time all in one place and all on your
terms so if you would like a website you
know for a side hustle you're starting
or your eCommerce business it can be
really daunting to create a website
because you know people go to college
for years to learn how to code
Squarespace is so easy
so they have a ton of different product
features that make your website really
stand out like you can you know sell
custom merch and create a passive income
stream that engages your audience you
can also create an online store where
you can sell your own products on an
online store they have great um features
like email campaigns where you can drive
sales and engage your audience with
Squarespace email campaigns you easily
collect email subscribers on your site
and build connections and repeat
business through regular email updates
so whatever type of website you're
trying to create Squarespace has a
template for that they have a feature
for that it's so easy
and it's um just like the best in my
opinion platform out there to create to
get a professional looking website out
there so head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com toast to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain again
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain today's episode is also brought
to you by game time buying tickets to
your favorite events should not be
stressful game time is the fast and easy
way to buy tickets for all the sports
music comedy and theater near you with
killer deals on last minute tickets and
their best price guarantee you can stop
stressing over the tickets and start
getting hyped for the fun you're going
to have at the actual event so game time
is the place for last minute ticket
deals you don't have to plan months in
advance anymore game time is deals on
tickets right up to the day of the event
so get exclusive Flash Deals on tickets
for football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater and more and the
game time guarantee means you'll get the
best price so if you find tickets in the
same section in row for Less game time
will credit you not a hundred but 110 of
the difference and it's the fastest
growing ticket app in the country for a
reason get images of your seats before
you buy so you know exactly what to
expect when you arrive you can buy
tickets in a matter of seconds it's
literally two Taps on your phone and
you're all set tickets are then sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email like holding
up the line being like sorry let me just
pull up this PDF no it's all on your
phone it's so easy
um it's a great app to have on your
phone if you travel a lot and you find
yourself you know with a night off
in a fabulous City You Know download the
game time app see what that city has to
offer snag the tickets without the
stress with Game Time download the game
time app create an account and use code
toast for 20 off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code toast for 20 off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price guaranteed thank you
Claudia
welcome uh the movie about the British
Schindler is called one life I just had
to put a pin in that and that sounds
appropriate
it does for it's gonna be at like the
Tiff it's gonna be a big movie so sounds
like a reference to the talmudic verse
to save one life is to save a thousand
is to save the world
oh yeah even bigger
even better oh Humanity seven billion
any any identical Australian charity
okay let's get into the stories our
first story is so crazy some news that's
Rock The Sports World LeBron James's son
bronnie who's 18 suffered a cardiac
arrest during USC basketball practice
LeBron James's son bronny suffered
cardiac arrest on Monday during
basketball practice at the University of
Southern California the 18 year old
athlete was taken to a hospital where he
was treated in ICU before being released
to General care
um the rep for the family said yesterday
while practicing bronnie James suffered
a cardiac arrest medical staff was able
to treat bronnie and take him to the
hospital he's now in stable condition
and is no longer in the ICU we ask for
respect and privacy for the James family
and we will update media when there's
more information
that's so crazy because this is someone
like a young person who's in Peak
Physical Fitness
son I'm sure he's probably gonna have
like an insane career in the NBA
um so scary mm-hmm
I hope he's okay yeah
and this reminds me of that story from
last year about
um the Bills players collapse on the
field Demar Hamlin who also I believe he
had Cardiac Arrest correct yeah
so terrible yes I think that Demar
Hamlin had like spoken out yesterday
about like sending love to brownie
um yeah so terrible and so scary and
who who knows what this could mean but
like brownie has made so many
headlines like for being you know the
next big thing in sports and I'm pretty
sure in the background of one of Zach's
shows a few months ago I heard the
broadcaster saying that LeBron said that
whatever team picks up his son he will
go to
okay let's give him like nipple baby
first of all yeah but like why not
you know that's that's very interesting
because like I was thinking before when
we were just talking about him his son
you know nepotism in sports I can't
really be a thing
you just have to be good it's based on
numbers points scored you know free
throw range whatever but this is
actually like an interesting way of
being like nepotistic in
Sports yeah and using like all of his
power and influence to get the best deal
for his son now would this be the I have
to assume yes the first time a father
and son have played on a team together
and by the time he gets to the NBA will
LeBron still be in the NBA I think so
bronny's 18. I don't know at what age
um
but he's at USC yeah but like they can
miss like is it like football where you
can like draft early
yeah and even still even in five years
like LeBron's gonna be a better
basketball player then yeah no but he's
not slowing down then people 10 20 years
younger than him so yeah
that's cool plus even like to like say
LeBron's not
scoring like he used to be like to have
the James's on your team like that sells
tickets it's an interesting proposition
it's pretty cool yeah it's pretty cool
yeah I feel like at some point like
after LeBron's career he'll probably
become like an owner of a team I feel
like that happens a lot with like those
major major players
um and it'd be cool I don't know if
there's like rules against it if he was
like the owner of the team that his son
was on yeah well if he was the owner of
a team he could draft whoever he wants
right
not really that's like not your job it's
like general manager for sure but like
you own the team so if the general
manager won't do it like you could fire
them
you could you could you could you could
yeah so I guess that's where nepotism
could play into it as well but if he's
having
um cardiac issues that could affect his
Sports career so I know I think
everyone's kind of
worried and waiting and seeing
well I wish him well truly yeah me too
are you ready for our next story
yes Megan Fox is being ripped to bits
for asking fans to donate to her Pals
GoFundMe
so this is like a very interesting
celebrity Trope that I see happen a lot
my most favorite you know one is Lady
Gaga asking for GoFundMe donations for
her dad's restaurant it's a girl help
out
yeah okay it's a literally your dad
here's the details on this one because
it always changes Megan Fox has been
slammed for asking her Instagram
followers to donate to a friend's
GoFundMe rather than coughing up all the
money herself the fundraiser which had a
goal of thirty thousand dollars was set
up for her Nail Tech Britney's father
who was diagnosed with cancer it's
seeking to raise the same amount that
Megan's fiance Machine Gun Kelly spent
on a diamond encrusted manicure last
year the the story notes so Megan took
her Instagram story Monday night with a
picture of the GoFundMe she put it on
her Instagram story saying my friend's
dad was just diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer if you guys are able to help
please do fans of the actress whose net
worth is estimated to be around 8
million dollars we're confused as to why
she would request donations on social
media rather than picking up the bill
herself
a bunch of commenters said the highest
donation is only 300 and it's not
Anonymous CIS better contribute herself
and Lead the Way someone else said if I
had as much money as her I'd cover 100
of a friend's parents medical expenses
before I asked strangers too
um so that's the argument that she
should pay for this and not ask her fans
to I mean there's a lot of arguments to
be made you know for Megan what's her
name Fox to pay the whole thing and I
think you know one of the biggest
arguments is that it's thirty thousand
dollars which is a lot of money not for
a celebrity like they literally get paid
fifty thousand dollars just to wear a
shirt from a brand like if she wanted to
make this 30k back she could do it in a
day so it's tacky I'm sorry it's tacky
and to not have the wherewithal to like
donate first like ten thousand dollars
with like it could say Anonymous but
everyone would know it was her because
that's what people do they go to
GoFundMe is you can sort the donations
by highest to lowest and you could see
who did you know the big one and so
is it possible that Megan Fox privately
helped this girl out of course oh true
true but in this day and age you got to
be a little bit more clogged you know
yeah especially because this has
literally happened before copy and paste
I remember Kylie was in trouble for this
too but yeah also like this might sound
crazy and I guess I didn't know her net
worth was eight million dollars I know
what you're gonna say that seems kind of
high to me like I feel like
I guess she was in Transformers which is
a huge movie yeah but she doesn't act
that much no that's definitely true
maybe Megan Fox is like I don't know you
go to the Met Gala you got 30 grand no I
don't think so
no all those things that Megan Fox does
like
aren't like paying gigs no she's always
making news but never for work she's
always reading mood news she's never
making money
It's actually an amazing point like I
don't know the last time she was in a
film right except Transformers is like
the kind of movie that I think confuse
you until you die
yeah
she definitely like
she's known for Transformers Jennifer's
Body which is like an indie okay but
that doesn't make like you know so much
money
okay so Transformers was in 2007.
but she was into two Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle movies 2014 and 2016. nose
feel like big money makers too okay but
like even if they paid her a couple
million dollars for those movies like
those were years ago and I'm sure she
lives like a high
okay here's what she's done recently I
have not heard of one of these things
most recently she was in Dave in one
episode okay so let's just Johnny and
Clyde
I don't know her
good morning spelled m-o-u-r-n-i-n-g
big gold brick
Taurus
Knight teeth
till death
midnight switchgrass that's the Randall
Emmett one
oof Machine Gun Kelly's music video
Rogue
think like a dog
Machine Gun Kelly's music video okay
the battle of jangsari
zeroville
above the Shadows
then the first thing I've heard of is
from 2016. she was in 15 episodes of New
Girl
okay that's seven years ago
I think that's really the but I'm sorry
over the course of her career this is
40. New Girl Jennifer's Body
Transformers uh Transformers again
there's three Transformers movies
yeah those Transformers once I think you
know
can set you up for the rest of your life
she did a hundred episodes of a show
called Ocean Avenue this has 30
grand lying around I'm sorry and then by
the way and then there's other things
you get paid for actually a lot of money
for outside of acting especially
somebody in the Marv in the in the
Marvel Universe like all those you know
events she's fine yeah and is she
married yet no no are they still
together even
I don't know yeah and like I genuinely
don't care yeah I mean we could go back
and forth and whether she you know now
because she was in Transformers needs to
pay everyone's medical bills around her
for the rest of her life but I think the
idea of like kicking it to her fans
is weird is weird but what if it was
like her friend who was like could you
post about this like we could use some
more eyes on it
if somebody said like to it like you
have to think like
they would never ask can you pay this
they would say can you post this because
that's like nothing but like a normal
human being would be like let me just
pay it if I'm Megan Fox
I don't know
I don't think she's that liquid
that's definitely possible I don't know
what sort of financial decision she's
made she had a messy divorce let's not
forget about that where she was
definitely the earner
yeah
so but to not even put five thousand
like on like come on yeah but you're
right she could have paid offline
she could have paid offline even though
there's already like a donation set up I
think would just be like a lot easier
but okay yeah yeah
instead of having to explain link to
your accountant in this like wire
transfer
right now I actually read yesterday that
all the money GoFundMe is like kind of
like a crazy platform all the money that
was raised for that Carly Russell woman
who fake abducted herself like they
can't get it back
that's weird
right because GoFundMe does sometimes
like step in and they'll like shut down
phone raisers
um so to not like
get it back is weird weird but I thought
Carly Russell's family was not accepting
donations for her reward
like when when it happened I thought
that was so interesting when I read that
I was like they weren't looking for
donations for a reward like they had a
reward set up
but I did see what you saw about like
people can't get their donations back so
obviously they donated somewhere I think
oh I think a lot of people donated to
Crime Stoppers
like in the in the hopes of supporting
the Carly Russell's search
63 000 raised from donors and Carly
Russell case is not being refunded from
Crime Stoppers okay so let's not
GoFundMe
so Crime Stoppers of metro Alabama said
on Monday that the 63 000 in reward
money raised to help find Carly Russell
is not being returned to donors despite
her safe return
I'm Russell who vanished in Alabama last
Thursday yada yada Crime Stoppers
initially said that it would give back
the sixty three thousand dollars donated
during the search for the missing
nursing student before saying in the
afternoon that the money would not be
refunded the investigation is still
ongoing and accordingly there is no
basis to refund any contributions at
this time furthermore the Hoover Police
Department has not requested for any
donor contributions to be released or
refunded it's not clear how much money
has since been returned through the
group's website on Wednesday still
displayed a notice of a reward being
offered
but now we know like yeah but when you
donate to Crime Stoppers is that like a
larger organization or like you earmark
it for Carly
I think you can earmark it to be like
you know incentivize people with a
reward but yes you're right I guess that
63 000 could be dispersed like you know
six others right right it's not like
it's going to Carly as a reward for
faking her own abduction that's true so
hopefully it gets used for a good cause
if they really don't return it but
that's really murky
yeah
well so oh sorry go back to Megan Fox
she definitely has money she might not
be as liquid as we thought she would but
in the group in the grand scheme of like
celebrity money 30 grand is not a lot
yeah and she could have donated 10. but
and she did okay but like I mean I would
expect her to be more
as you said clogged than this but like
what if she donated like 20 000 offline
and that and like maybe the bill was
fifty thousand now they're trying to
raise the additional 30. 100 a
possibility and that's why it's just
never a good idea for like a big
celebrity to post a GoFundMe unless it's
like a GoFundMe that's
um like millions of dollars needed you
know you're like I feel like after like
a a really a tragedy yes hurricane or
you know something there's always a
GoFundMe setup with like an endless goal
just to raise the most amount of money
for the families who lost someone so
that's different but like for a personal
friend Kylie's gotten in trouble Lady
Gaga now Megan Fox like we need to learn
they need to learn it should be like a
no-go Zone okay I totally agree with you
and that's the takeaway here but I just
want to give you like a situation
okay because what if the total bill was
like sixty thousand dollars and Megan
was like I'll pay half so now they only
need to raise thirty thousand dollars
and then she posts like Britney asked
her to post the link so she posts the
link and now she's in all this hot water
like Megan can never come forward and
say no guys I paid 30 to her before like
she can never even defend herself about
this because it's like
you don't know and by the way when
somebody needs money like we should not
be thinking about things like this it's
so stupid but like that is the world
that we live in and so if that was the
case like Megan should have done the 30
like anonymously on GoFundMe because
people would have flocked to go see like
what the biggest donation was they would
have saw 30 assume it was Megan and be
like oh okay so she donated and she's
promoting but what if she donated before
she knew there was going to be a
GoFundMe
sure it's not like she can just like hop
on stories and then just start talking
about like how much she donated how much
she didn't she's never gonna like give
air to this so we're just gonna like
keep saying that she didn't donate more
than 300 and then also then say like the
friend was like hey could you could
promote this like you have you know we
could use some more eyes like how do you
say no to your friend this is bad for my
image that's rude yeah
it's a tough spot I'm just saying not
that I agree with her I'm just saying I
I can recognize she's in a tough spot
you know I agree and there's like a
million scenarios where she did the
right tails that we don't know 100
000 already yeah a hundred percent 100
100 but we are given information and we
have to come to conclusions with solely
the information we're giving I think the
takeaway is that we can't just jump to
conclusions and assume the worst of
great people
agreed but celebrities need to
you know even if someone's asking them
to post their GoFundMe like you could
say like I think this would backfire I
don't know
I think
we can reserve judgment there's
definitely like a Litany of details that
we do not know but I think we can all
agree when Lady Gaga did it for her
dad's restaurant that was weird yes
totally
great
I'm glad we worked through that
it's complicated thing it is considering
we don't know everything
are you ready for our next story
eagle-eyed history Buffs are pointing
out an error in Christopher Nolan's
Oppenheimer Blockbuster that's commonly
made in World War II movies and it's I
heard this it's unfortunate it really is
yeah I would have never noticed it but
people did
so um the movie focuses uh on a Time
1945 World War II and one scene in the
movie
um after Japan's surrender and the US
victory in the war they show Oppenheimer
being applauded by an audience waving
the flag but eagle-eyed viewers have
pointed out that the flags that they're
waiting have 50 stars rather than 48
even though Hawaii and Alaska did not
become U.S states until 1959.
so yeah okay like who the is
Counting Stars I'm sure that's what
Christopher Nolan said like Oh No One's
Gonna count the Stars it's fine no I
don't think I think if they knew
that the stars were off they would have
fixed if they put so much care and
detail into these movies like I'm sure
it's killing him that like he made this
big epic it's so you know I'm sure I
haven't seen it and I don't know the
story but I'm gonna say historically
accurate to a degree and they're getting
by these flags and everyone's
talking about the black queen it's
giving American Sniper Chris Kyle and
the fake baby
yeah that was weird
um did you see the Tweet of like the
woman she went viral I'm pretty sure she
like deleted her whole account and it
was like
just want to let you guys know there was
not a woman for the first 20 minutes in
Oppenheimer and it's like yeah it was
literally 1940 whatever whatever what
year was it 1945.
yeah it's like well that would make it
incredibly historically accurate right
that's so funny did you see the tweet
that was like you guys I'm worried about
Barb and Heimer like sweat and covid
like just be like everyone going to the
movies and they're being like
and there being another coveted pandemic
okay
um moving on I think it was from a
doctor too
like it wasn't just a layperson being
like right a freak
um
so the Stars so the thing is do I care
no would I have noticed this no do I
think it takes away from like the
Integrity or the you know validity of
the film also now
but it's not like it's not a hundred
percent
to me like the bar for inaccuracies and
like flops will always be when somebody
left a plastic water bottle in the
background of games no Starbucks cup too
whatever yeah
this is so much better than that so I'm
okay I know but like imagine you make a
perfect movie and then it's not perfect
thus you know further proving my point
that you know we're all just people it's
true how one how did people even notice
this is my question I'm saying like
their waving flags they're not even
standing still for a minute you can't
even sit there and count them and well
maybe the it was because it was 48 like
maybe the alignment of stars is
different
yeah but also like I'm sure they have so
many history Buffs on set like how do
you like lay people notices and not the
experts
you know it's a win for the lay people
and apparently according to the Daily
Mail like this is a mistake that happens
in a lot of movies around World War II
so how did we not learn from this right
like learn from others mistakes
maybe they could use AI to fix it fix it
in like when it goes out to On Demand
I'm sorry this is humiliating it's a
stain on Christopher Nolan's record he
should never work again
take
I mean yeah if you
think Stars right like what are you
doing can you count why bother why
bother
right are you dumb
[Laughter]
so humiliating like I definitely knew
that Hawaii and Alaska were only added
to the Union in the 50s like I 100 knew
that yeah of course you did you read the
rose code
no by God that's what I'm saying maybe
if Christopher Nolan had read The Rose
code we wouldn't be having this
conversation it's like
to know how much doesn't that's his
cross to bear
not our problem sorry Chris you're on
your own
sorry are you ready for our next story
Ariana Grande's boyfriend's wife feels
that he abandoned their family
TMZ no TMZ has learned that Aries and
Ethan's relationship came as a surprise
to the actors now estranged wife who
feels he abandoned his family sources
close to the wife Lily J tell us she's
devastated her family's been torn apart
she's also upset their young son who was
born in August 2022 wow one year ago
won't have both his mom and dad around
constantly now that they've split TMZ
sources say Lily and Ethan aren't on
good terms now that the Ariana
relationship is full steam ahead Lily
feels like he's turned his back
completely on his family
now that I've had some time to think on
this
um and it's like started to marinate
when we were first reported on it like I
was like lol you know Ari ruining lives
but like artists ruining lives like it
actually is really not sitting well with
me and for what this relationship is
gonna go nowhere first of all it's like
a fun set it's like a camp romance
because they were just like all together
filming this film it's I'm actually like
not to be such a loser who needs
to touch grass but like
I expected more from Ariana she needs to
do better yeah I mean of course it's up
to this man like he has agency and
choice but like I'm sure he thinks that
like Ari loves him and and he's gonna
leave it all in risk it all for Ari but
like we know this relationship is gonna
last three months and it's really
especially up to do with a
one-year-old like are you kidding any
man in the world like this little nerd
taking him from his family like you know
it's not right now and especially like
I'm just seeing the Barbie movie which
was like very much like Womanhood is his
Sisterhood like and it's on the man 100
but like already knew and like she could
have looked out for her fellow sister in
Christ but she didn't no she didn't and
like
and she's the one with power here like
I'm sorry this guy's a free like
whenever he comes to you and says like
leave your wife and child and be with me
like we're womenly wise like I I would
say yes well no not like of course not
baby Harry
no but like she's the biggest star in
the world she's you know this Larger
than Life he was like and I hate to like
place blame on the woman because if the
roles were reverse gender roles we would
be saying the same thing if it was a
huge man on set and he had this like
woman and also the man was Notorious for
just having no offense like a revolving
door of relationships that seemed so
serious but are not yep then we would
say the exact same thing
and I guess what Ariana would say is
screw Sisterhood you know yeah and
that's what she's very Victor Garber
that's what she said this is just really
sad and
confusing it's not by the way it's
really not a good look for Ariana like
it's just not yeah
but it really hasn't touched her like I
feel like
she's Untouchable yeah she is
Untouchable but no one's really saying
this
it's kind of just like funny to everyone
no I know and that's what it was for me
too but now I've sort of sat with it and
it's like this this mother this wife who
literally never wants us to be a part of
this narrative one in which she never
asked to be a part of and now her whole
life is destroyed and now she's like in
the media her Instagram's being
infiltrated like leave this woman alone
she just married this theater nerd and
wanted a nice quiet life and she has a
one-year-old terrible honestly it's
terrible I'm sorry honestly I'm sorry I
joked about it like because now it
really has not sat well with me no she's
a one-year-old and daddy ran off with
Ariana Grande like
it's so inconceivable
it's so wrong
it's you know what it is it's wrong do
better Ari
yeah
there's plenty of single men and she
could have any of them anyone anyone not
only is she like so beautiful she's so
famous anyone like there's no reason she
went for this Freak No and it's like I
feel as though anytime she sets her
sights on someone like they will date
it's not giving Irene yeah it's giving
like she has
she's a very Charming person unlimited
option no people are really drawn to her
yeah
this is a bad joke there was no reason
for this especially because let me tell
you something I can't see the future I'm
Not Raven Simone but this will not last
I am Raven Simone and I can tell you it
won't last
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
final story yeah Blake Lively jumps over
the ropes at Kensington Palace to fix
the display of her 2022 metcal address
have you seen this
no on Tuesday the Gossip Girl Alum
posted an Instagram story of her jumping
over the ropes at London's Kensington
Palace they have an exhibit called Crown
to Couture and they have her Mecca
address from this year on display so in
the video she hops over the rope and uh
fixes her dress she said when you're the
clown who hops over the Rope at the
Museum to fix the exhibit happy almost
Virgo season folks
oh so the rules don't apply to Blake
Lively well is it her dress
definitely not her dress appears
alongside 200 other pieces at the
exhibit inside Princess Diana's former
home including a former lizzo look Lady
Gaga the exhibition also features a
number sounds like a cool display it
does sound like a cool display it
features a number of historic gowns as
it tells the story of how Rock and red
carpet fashion has been influenced by
the Royals of the Georgian era in the
19th in the 18th century so I guess her
Met Gala look this year was influenced
by the Georgian era which is possible
cool but like you know what this is
giving you know
not only is it a museum where you're not
supposed to touch anything
but it's like at Kensington Palace where
you're also not supposed to touch
anything I don't know I don't really
like her bragging about this like like I
I buy like I'm a rule follower yeah but
what if it was your dress like what if
it was your retro features and they
didn't have like the bow tied in the way
that you wore it and it was an exhibit
like about 30 through the years I would
ask someone to fix it like
you know one time I went to a wedding
you don't think that's like more
self-indulged like Taps like instead of
just like running and diying it
no don't put your grubby hands on the
display like these are now considered
works of art they're in a museum like
don't touch it yeah there are ropes
there for a reason
wow now one time I went to a wedding at
the Met
and it was beautiful and I posted on my
Instagram like that I was at the med
after dark it was very cool and I like
joked that I was like touching something
I didn't touch it but I was like oh oh
somebody from the museum there was like
security everywhere and like hours later
I just had seen my Instagram came over
and I was like oh look a fan she wants a
photo she was like please delete your
Instagram I'm like oh okay I got in
trouble like my whole night was around
I'm sorry
yeah so I like and that's how I had to
learn my lessons became about turkey
yeah I had to learn my lesson and I
think Blake should be I think she should
be spoken to reprimanded yeah it is also
kind of giving like awesome Butler
Vanessa how Jim's putting their initials
on that journey I thought that too I
literally thought that too like look how
cute we are we're putting our initials
in a trait boom citation yeah I mean it
it begs the question like who does the
dress belong to it did but maybe Blake
loaned it to the museum in which case
she's free to touch it however she wants
or maybe it depends who runs the museum
maybe they'll think this is like a
quirky thing that she did you know
bringing a little to promote
to the exhibit and to promote like the
the exhibit which sounds like a
wonderful exhibit and I hope it makes
its way to the US which I it actually
does I mean it would be fun like I feel
like we could play a game where like we
would go to Every
dress and see how many of the 200 we
could place as to who wore it because
what that's what we do for a living like
I'm telling you I feel like we could do
all 200 if they're spanning the last
like five ten years I don't think that
they are I think they're spending the
last like 200 years
then definitely not but
I will click on the link and try and
find more
of the dresses oh yeah these are like
Renaissance look oh goodness Luke's from
the Renaissance
loose
well thanks Jax for that Fast Five just
really ran the gamut I feel good about
it but I'm so excited because we're not
even done we're not even close to being
done um
Wednesday our weekly advice segment so
every Wednesday we do an advice segment
called deer toasters and you guys
basically write to us about what you're
going through we do our best to help you
now if you would like to submit please
note that it's completely Anonymous and
there are two ways to submit the first
is going to the toastpodcast.com there's
a little submission box when you scroll
down
perfect there or you can just shoot us
an email to your toasters gmail.com now
deer toasters is brought to you
by better tomorrow are you ready to
embark on a transformative Journey
towards a better tomorrow we'll join the
captivating TV personality Hannah Brown
on her new lifestyle podcast that will
leave you inspired and empowered so you
of course know Hannah from The
Bachelorette and of course Dancing with
the Stars but now you can go deep with
her to ask every week am I better today
than I was yesterday so Hannah takes you
on a deep dive into topics that matter
most from confidence to love and making
time for yourself Hannah share's
relatable experiences as the ultimate
Every Woman brace yourself for advice
that hits home intimate emotional
Explorations and eye-opening reveals as
a progressive empowered woman of Faith
Hannah challenges societal Norms guides
her audience and ignites meaningful
conversations and of course Hannah is no
expert she's actively defining and
deciding what it all means and figuring
it out along the way so get ready for a
better tomorrow because your journey
starts here you can listen to better
tomorrow every Wednesday wherever you
get your podcast so of course you know
all the play places and that's better
tomorrow hosted by Hannah Brown comes
out every Wednesday wherever you get
your podcasts today's episode is also
brought to you by the farmer's dog
whether you have a few weeks old puppy
or a senior who's seen multiple decades
any dog person like Jax and I knows that
the most valuable thing in the world is
spending time with your pet and the
farmer's dog can help keep them healthy
which can give you more quality years
with them so the farmer's dog makes and
delivers fresh healthy dog food it's
recommended by vets it's nutritionally
balanced and it's made from human grade
ingredients in safe clean kitchens
it's the best option for dogs at all
stages because it's not kibble it's not
canned goo it's real food traditional
dry and wet food dog options are
extremely processed they can use much
lower quality ingredients than they
cling to and are difficult to portion
accurately but the farmer's dog isn't
just higher quality food they also send
the food in pre-portioned um little bags
it's specifically designed for your dog
based on their unique nutritional needs
so it makes every um it makes it very
helpful to and easy to maintain your
dog's weight which can be one of the
biggest indicators of a full healthy
life so I switched to uh Farmer's dog a
few months ago and Theo was seemingly
you know before that like a totally fine
Healthy dog but there were so many
benefits Ever Since switching his breath
is so much better his coat is shiny he
makes like normal sized poops he's super
regular so it doesn't matter if your dog
is old or young it's always the right
time to begin investing in their health
helping you live a more healthy happy
and full years together get 50 off your
first box when you go to the
farmersdog.com toast that's the
farmersdog.com toast for 50 off your
first box of the farmer's dog all right
checks are you ready for deer toasters
ready
hey Jackson Claude huge fan of the show
found you guys on Tick Tock I listen
every day I recently found out that my
grandfather made a tick tock account
which I thought was funny and cute I
clicked on his profile and I noticed
that he was following hundreds of people
already I was shocked and befuddled to
see was exclusively following hundreds
of like spicy thirst trap accounts sexy
anime cosplayers and what appear to be
like only fan promotion Pages they all
feature women who are about my age
what's even worse is I don't think he
knows that anyone can see that
information of who he follows at family
gatherings he goes on and on about how
he's a total Tick-Tock addict and now
I'm literally so grossed out and
uncomfortable hearing this should I tell
him I can see who he follows or should I
just keep this haunting information to
myself sincerely a traumatized toaster I
think now my rebuttal my rebuttal
includes three words let grandpa live
yes same I was going to say let Gramps
live just to add like a little sexy
Flair let grandpa live like stop he
obviously doesn't know that you can see
it he would be mortified if he did leave
him alone yeah also how old are you that
they're your age
um
no way Jackie I took everything in me
not to read it how would you feel if
your father came up with someone great
yeah no probably like 25 or 30 like it's
not like it's underage like these are
consensual females who are looking for
audiences and your grandpa right your
grandpa's supporting women in business
supporting female creators listen let me
live I'm not worried what is he gonna do
with this have a little fun I
leave him alone I assume he's not
married or he's a widowed because she
would have said that like my grandma so
he's fine leave him alone old people
need vices too and his is completely
harmless so you just keep your little
trap shot okay okay but I have a
question for you how would you feel if
he was married to Grandma
I would still think it's okay yeah right
like what is he gonna he's gonna cheat
on Grandma like
now I literally think it's you can get
his little sticks also if it's on Tick
Tock it's not like it's porn it's just
you probably suggest true is it just do
female content
and I'm sure that they're out there
promoting their only fans and your
grandpa has quite literally no clue what
only fans is how to download it how to
put his credit card information in he's
literally consuming Tick Tock safe
content which can be provocative for
sure but
what are their nudity there's no disease
there's no tits ass like you can't show
nipple but you could wear like a thought
but I think even still I think still it
would get taken down okay yeah I think
Grandpa is living his best life like why
only can you be on Tick Tock like
I would just instead of the feelings
you're feeling which are definitely like
discomfort and grossed out why don't you
try and channel like some some positive
energy for grandpa being like you know
he's old he's getting up there there's
probably not so many things that bring
him joy and this is one of those things
and so if I can just put my discomfort
aside I know that my grandpa's like out
here living a full happy borderline
erect life then we all win it's true and
as far as you knowing this information
and like feeling weird about it that's
your cross to bear
yeah we that's the thing about getting
older it's like we end up finding things
out about like parents grandparents that
you didn't know when you were a kid and
definitely like shakes your core
you gotta get over it yeah you don't
need to have like a family session if
someone else in the family notices it
and brings it up like you guys can Bond
over it but giggle grandpa is living
let grandpa live
all right next up dear Jackson turdy Lou
I'm in desperate need of some advice I
recently broke up with my boyfriend who
was the first person I ever slept with I
never felt regretful when we had sex
because we loved each other but now that
I'm out of a relationship I feel so
gross and for having sex and not
waiting till I'm closer with a person I
need some advice to help me stop
slut-shaming myself thank you I love you
guys I listen every day I feel like
that's well it's so harsh I feel like
there's two routes we can take here the
first is like I don't know if you need
to hear this but there's literally
nothing wrong with like having sex with
another consenting adult it's liberating
people do it all the time there's
nothing wrong with it go off Queen get
your bag but also I do think there are a
lot of people who don't have casual sex
and exclusively like wait till they're
like seeing someone exclusively or in a
relationship and that's okay too so
maybe you might be one of those people
no she is one of those people and I
think you know the idea of two
concerning adults go off Queen have sex
like that doesn't work for everyone but
she was in a relationship with this
person so that's why I feel like you're
being so hard on yourself like you you
said Jackie Jackie you're
misunderstanding she said she was in a
room she's at she's out of the
relationship okay
and now she's out of a relationship she
feels gross and
for having sex with like other people
like dating and stuff really I read it
as she was in a relationship
and she had sex let me read it okay
I recently woke up with my boyfriend who
was the first person I ever slept with I
never felt regretful when we had sex
because we loved each other okay but now
that I'm out of a relationship I feel so
gross and for having sex and not
waiting till I'm closer with the person
okay by the way you could read it as
what you saw or whatever no because yeah
no
but I'm I'm
because she said we loved each other so
you never regret having sex with someone
you like right but she it also sounded
like when she did it she didn't regret
it but now that she's out of the
relationship like maybe she didn't think
they were as close as she thought and
now she regrets it but why would she not
think that she's close with the person
that she's in a relationship with and
loves wait this is like actually
confusing no no okay it could be both
but I will go with yours because I do
think that makes like a little more
sense
yeah and I believe it's like a thing you
know of course they give like a label to
everything now I think it's called
demisexual but like you can really only
be intimate with someone you're like
deeply
um like care for and love which like
isn't a sexuality I just think it's like
I think it's the same way that's so
crazy that that's a word for there's a
word wanting to love the person that
you're with right so I think like both
routes are totally fine but I don't
think you need to like
change it might just be that you're that
type of person and that's totally okay
yeah and you don't have to have sex with
people if that's not making you making
you feel good or feel good or like
you're it's making you feel worse after
the fact like then don't be that person
there are so many people who don't want
to do that and don't do that like maybe
you feel pressure because I mean I guess
it's the societal Norm now is just
casual sex but that doesn't work for
everyone
no and I think there's like a a huge
group of people who still abide by like
you know not having sex with someone
until they're like involved exclusively
or in a relationship and that's totally
okay yeah and I think it doesn't look
weird or a loser it goes for both men
and women too yeah so I think ultimately
like if you if you make decisions like
based on how you truly feel even if it's
not the popular one or the cool one
right it will lead you to the right
person
yeah so I would just like follow your
feelings you don't have to change your
feelings just because you think they're
like weird or whatever like yeah you
feel that way for a reason and that's
totally and like and instead of feeling
gross about it it taught you a lesson
like now you know this about yourself
like do with that yes use that
information don't just discard it and
keep like pushing through and being
someone that you're not
you can be grateful for the lesson and
not feel shame because the lesson
brought you the less clarity the clarity
right
um that was confusing thank you
all right our third and final one is
like making my blood boil we absolutely
have to sharpen our pitchforks because
we ride it John okay okay I'm ready
I watch you girlies every day I love you
both so much I'm one year postpartum and
I'll be 30 in a few months my husband
and I were having dinner with our best
friends who are also a married couple
and I told my girlfriend that I want to
start working out
um and for her to hold me accountable I
told her that I wanted to be in the best
possible shape of my life for my 30th
birthday which is coming up she quickly
responded with but okay but you don't
need to you really look great my husband
chuckled a little and said she could
stand to lose 10 pounds
I was mortified the other husband
changed the subject to sports and my
husband and I haven't spoken about it
yet how do I approach this am I right
for feeling upset so you approach it
with a shotgun with a knife yeah there's
so many reasons as to why this is
up and I don't know which is the worst
whether it's like him even commenting on
your weight but I honestly think it's
worse that he did it in front of us yeah
no that he's so dumb that he thought
that was an okay thing to say in general
he thought it was okay to say it to you
and he thought it was okay to say it in
front of other people like the way this
man needs his ass ringed out maybe he
really is just that dumb and like not I
mean if you've gained sometimes it's
like if you've gained weight I'm sorry
you're a father now there's literally no
excuse for being that dumb no but people
it's irresponsible it's honestly for you
it is irresponsible to be so strong
through the world being so oblivious and
so dumb
honestly I think this calls for you
sitting him down and playing in this
episode now listen sir
you're literally disgusting I'm sure
you're fat okay
and your wife who by the way just had a
baby
is a queen and the fact that she hasn't
stabbed you in your sleep you
should be so goddamn grateful for that I
need you to get some perspective first
of all never ever in your goddamn life
talk about your wife's body postpartum
or not it's none of your
business okay also you wear a mask in
that situation right oh yeah easy
shopping we weren't talking to you
now the second thing that is so
important for a husband to learn and the
fact that you haven't learned this makes
me just I understand you're dumb and
maybe Nobody Told You So I'm gonna tell
you
when you're out in public with your wife
your job is to lift her up your job is
to protect her but if the call is coming
from inside the house if somebody's out
here in public embarrassing me and it's
the person I sleep next to the
person who's supposed to love me most in
this world you are not the person I hate
most in this world and your wife I don't
know if she does but she should
hate you and you have a lot of work to
do sir on yourself
on being a better version for your
daughter for her son excuse me for your
wife and all I can say in a non-ironic
way is do better yeah no
you can't walk through this world being
that dumb
I fear you're gonna hit by a car you're
so dumb yeah you're gonna get taken
event like you to not know that that's
so wrong the wrong thing to say
in front of other people like that makes
it so much worse like of course in the
privacy of your own home it's still a
up thing to say but then you're
adding like another level of humiliation
to the rage you already feel I can't I'm
girly I'm so sorry this is what we have
to put up with it's just like women who
you know are married I but it's it's
unacceptable I'm so sorry you're a
stunning Queen you just birthed a human
take all the time you need yeah and
seriously
what if it wasn't even like a dumb thing
like what if it's just like a cruel
thing you know oh because I'm kind of
benefit of the doubt that he's just dumb
enough to say something like that
well if he's saying it in like a
malicious cruel way this is clearly a
person who's extremely like verbally
abusive and manipulative and like that's
honestly if that's what he's saying in a
cruel way to me it's such a red flag for
so many other worse things but you know
what what gives me Solace is I feel like
she would have included in her prom that
like he's he's always making comments
yeah yeah yeah so so maybe we can go
back to dumb because the alternative
just like hurts my heart
if it is the alternative
run
but if he's just dumb and maybe like had
a few beers and thought he was being
funny
um we have to kill him yeah we have to
kill his spirit so that he never makes a
joke ever again because he worries that
it was the worst thing he could possibly
say
yeah I want this man to Never Smile
Again I want him to never contribute to
a conversation to never try and take a
stab at a joke
yeah because oh by the way sir if you're
still listening you're literally not
funny no we are we know funny I'm
literally a comedian I sold out Madison
Square Garden like I know funny you're
not funny you're dumb
so I think that's the advice here play
this episode for him yeah or if you
don't want to do that because we said
some unkind things to him and then maybe
that would cause a different fight yeah
so yeah and maybe just like this is your
little pocket of Peace where we can vent
about him and then you can like take
great take the applied lessons and apply
them
um you're so smart you're so smart rip
him a new one sometimes it's the best
especially if like this was really him
being dumb and not cruel like he needs
to sit down he needs an ass screaming
yeah and I would really
I would write your thoughts out because
like it's so annoying when like you're a
woman who's like mad about something and
then you just are like she's crazy but
it's like I have a reason for
being mad so your reasoning really needs
to be like well thought out like the
humiliation of saying something like
that period but then furthermore in
front of two people who like I care
about and respect is humiliating that
what are they going to think of me that
I'm just like you know some punching bag
for you and that's what our marriage is
that's not what our marriage is so why
would you want people to think that and
be like I know you probably think that I
look bad in this situation but actually
you made yourself look terrible I'm sure
they're talking about you and not me and
how they feel sorry for me to have to
put up with you
oh my God facts facts
because he's the one who should be
embarrassed even though it feels like
she's embarrassed he should he's the one
who should actually be embarrassed
because it reflected worse on him
I just want to say like I'm so mad but
the fact that you're postpartum and like
the worst thing he could say is that you
need to lose 10 pounds like you're
probably snatched so yeah feel good
about that literally that was like my
postpartum weight goals like 10 pounds
heavier yeah if someone was like after
I'm postpartum like they would say you
should get 10 to lose 100 pounds like
yeah you're fine so true
yeah no let's look into that actually
who actually loses the last 10 pounds of
anything oh
not even postpartum just in life in life
everyone could stand to lose 10 pounds
it's so true like congrats girly you
sound good congrats you got your goal
weight
no literally
I'm gonna hate this man I'm so sorry but
hopefully that was helpful advice and I
would absolutely love an update from you
just because I feel so invested
sometimes it's just nice to commiserate
and like have people validate how you
feel and like maybe yeah maybe we could
move like I mean what do what you need
to do but maybe you just need to get
that off your chest and needed us to get
as angry for you as you're feeling
no but it requires a conversation I
agree with that too but I do feel like a
little better after talking it through
because like I'm me too like I'm like
clenching
me too
um well those were your toasters again
dear toasters gmail.com is the email to
submit or the toastpodcast.com there's a
submission box they're totally Anonymous
thank you guys for submitting hopefully
we were helpful as we could be I thought
we were pretty helpful I think so and
that's our show our show nobody else's
they tried like the smartless guys are
always trying to be us yeah
yeah
thank you guys so much for listening to
the testimony Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories every
Monday Friday on YouTube so you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast with me down so
Spotify iTunes Studio public radio I
already castbox all the places if I
starve you about how beautiful standing
and what talented we are hope you guys
have an amazing Wednesday and we'll see
you tomorrow where we will officially be
entering the latter half of the week and
that's gorgeous love ya bye